ce parallèle constant entre votre vie
est la sienne et et vous comment c'est
d'ailleurs le livre par un des moments
les plus déterminants de votre vie c'est
la première fois que vous voyez johnny
hallyday en concert vous avez 9 ans et
vous écrivez c'est comme si j'avais vu
dieu en face de moi c'est exactement ça
c'était pour moi une révélation
il fallait il fallait que maintenant en
fait j'ai construit un parcours qui est
qui et qui est le mien qui est jean
baptiste guégan mais quand j'ai
rencontré johnny pour la première fois
de ma vie j'ai jamais rencontrée en les
rencontrant ça bien sûr non
malheureusement j'ai pas j'ai pas eu
cette chance
mais j'ai rencontré des gens autour
d'eux autour de lui aujourd'hui avec qui
je travaille donc michel mallory qui
m'écrit mes chansons et jeux dont j'en
suis très très fier vous savez c'est un
parcours quand même d'assez d'une longue
haleine quand même donc c'est quand même
assez spéciale ce qui m'arrivait mais
s'accroche mais c'est un truc de
l'entente gg j'ai passé en deux ans
depuis la france à un incroyable talent
puisque c'est vrai on en a parlé très
longuement et c'est vrai que la france à
la croix de temps ça a été un tremplin
pour moi mais avant avant d'aller jusque
là moi je voudrais revoir ce petit
garçon de 9 ans qui voit johnny pour la
première fois vous d'être carrément
envoyé dieu c'est vraiment ça qui s'est
passé oui c'est à dire que tu es mon
messi à moi et il fait toujours partie
de ma vie vous savez quand je monte sur
scène je n'y a pas une seule seconde où
je pense pas johnny hallyday
il est tout le temps présent il est tout
le temps présent
il fait partie de ma vie fait partie de
mon quotidien
il fait partie comme comme je raconte
dans le bouquin d'ailleurs comme mais ma
mère qui est partie comme mon père qui
est parti aussi d'ailleurs vous dites
dans une sorte de papa d'adoption même
si je n'ai jamais rencontré en quoi ça
peut être un papa d'adoption comment ben
c'était celui qui m'a qui m'a le plus
aidé dans ma vie c'est en fait je me
suis raccroché à ses chansons sa façon
d'être son son caractère sa vie en
général et ça a été quelqu'un pour moi
qui feint il fait 6 voilà mon mentor
coasser
je peux pas il n'y a pas un seul moment
où je pense pas johnny hallyday croyant
on va on va revenir justement sur ce
moment vous avez découvert johnny dans
un documentaire on est revenues regarder
j'assiste à un concert alors le
monument quoi le tipi sort du machin le
jour de ma naissance
[Musique]
m
la tuque
je sais même pas ce qui se passe
j'essaie de faire
je veux
j'ai pas dis je vais toujours johnny
hallyday c'est pas ça
[Musique]
l'alerté il a fait un million de
téléspectateurs c'était une vraie
surprise un succès incroyable c'est
parce que les gens moi j'ai l'impression
que johnny est peut-être un père de
substitution pour pour l'été le public
pour les téléspectateurs dès que vous
vous êtes un petit peu un johnny de
substitution est ce que vous le prenez
mal si je dis ça parce qu'on a
l'impression que ceux qui sont en manque
de johnny parce que johnny n'est plus là
ils se disent à bahia jean baptiste
quand même mais bien sûr mais en fait il
ya une magie qui sait qui c'est qui est
intervenu en fait c'est que
depuis tout ce chemin parcouru j'ai eu
cette chance d'avoir le d'avoir été
adoubé par le public ali desk et en même
temps j'ai j'ai aussi mon public qui
vient me voir et j'ai la chance d'avoir
toutes générations dans mes spectacles
d'ailleurs j'en fais un ce soir on en
parle d'ailleurs d'un geste après
l'émission bip vous filer la wii
normalement oui j'aimerais bien rester
un peu non mais c'est vrai que voilà
johnny ça a été dit là il a fait
énormément de choses dans ma vie m'a
aidé pour pour beaucoup de charme avant
dans votre livre d'ailleurs vous dit
j'aurais pu peut-être mal tourné même à
l'adolescence c'est johnny ses chansons
qui m'ont c'est grâce à lui que je suis
pas tombé dans la délinquance à ce point
là je oui oui parce que j'ai eu une
période de ma vie plusieurs périodes
dans ma vie où je ne savais pas qui
j'étais où il a fallu que je me cherche
il a fallu voilà je viens d'un milieu
modeste moi je ne suis pas née voilà on
m'a pas donné d étoiles direct
l'intérieur exactement là encore un
parallèle exactement mais on a on a le
même point commun si on regarde compte
si on regarde bien et qu'on découvre le
livre ça raconte vraiment l'histoire
mais son parcours est incroyable et pas
exactement pareil que celui à johnny
hallyday mais il est à peut sembler vous
fait effectivement le le va et vient
entre votre parcours et est le sien dans
dans le livre je rappelle un resté le
même et vous parle évidemment de l'école
le harcèlement
aujourd'hui vous parlez aussi de
l'alcool sans tabou parce qu'évidemment
on sait que tony bon bah il en a pas
fait secret il avait tendance à la
boisson et vous vous en parlez c'est ça
bien sûr j'en parle et j'ai pas honte de
ça
c'est une maladie l'alcool l'alcoolisme
est une maladie est faux moi je
personnellement j'y suis passé je me
suis fait soigner et puis tout va très
très bien même si ça peut m'arriver de
reboire encore un petit verre de temps
en temps mais tout tout tout se passe
très très bien en ce moment voir si
c'est plus un problème je le fais jamais
des problèmes ce n'est plus un fléau et
voilà parce que je me suis soigné parce
que dans ma tête j'ai fait une voilà
un travail problème simplement comme
beaucoup de personnes ont ce problème là
mais il faut en parler c'est important
parce que faut pas que ce soit à bout
mais non mais c'est comme le harcèlement
à l'école j'ai subi mois ddd a rich man
voilà des choses à l'école j'en parle
dans mon bouquin d'ailleurs
voilà enfin je veux dire faut en parler
voilà c'est tout faut il faut le dire